[Music]
[Music]
discovery we begin with narration as if
your dreams have no effect upon the
choices you make cool so my choices are
going to be based on insights gleaned
from being chased into my basement by
the wicked witch of the west who then
transformed into a toddler version of my
father who then reprimanded me for
harvesting the pineapples too soon great
but there is another life which awaits
you when you close your eyes show starts
by saying hey you know all those dreams
that were so strange you never told
anyone about them yeah those really
happened this may work like a discount
matrix land but there's still plenty to
sin look at this bridge for example the
design is visually staggering but i
don't want to be physically staggering
as it's lifted skyward to allow the ship
to pass underneath also if this is a
dream world why was the bridge
engineered in a way that doesn't allow
for naval traffic better yet why can't
the magical dream ships just pass right
through it sleep brings you here to find
freedom and adventure i'm sorry but i
can think of nothing i want to
experience less in my dreams than a
giant snoofle bear on my awesome ship
that looks like a recipe for trauma and
a broken
and nightmares that i create and the
best you could come up with to
demonstrate that as a [ __ ] pumpkin
janitor that looks suspiciously like
he's voiced by mark hamill really you
are coming back aren't you
why would i not return lucia i don't
know
a presentment to save you some googling
i'll just tell you that a presentament
is that funny feeling a character gets
that causes a sudden urge to foreshadow
something they really shouldn't have a
clue is about to happen i'm 25 certain i
have that right
here yes but with all these candles i
have to say not so much in the darkness
dr hathaway what an unexpected pleasure
no please no no more game of thrones i
beg you we don't need to do it anymore
okay sorry i'm i'm back i j just a bad
reaction to sudden not tywin just carry
on i take it you've reconsidered them my
son
edmund this destroyer was sunk last week
this is a phenomenal stroke of luck for
not tywin here we're about to learn that
dr hathaway possesses a book that not
tywin needs to summon a demon to
resurrect his son so if halfway son
hadn't died what was plan b we learned
that not tywin isn't exactly burdened
with a functioning moral compass so why
would he ever leave that initial meeting
with hathaway without the book as you
know i lost my son randall recently at
gallipoli a fact i know you know because
i've already told you but shall now tell
you again for the benefit of the
audience i understood that randall was
your only son charles dance hates one of
his fictional sons cliche tonight
we will achieve what no one before us
has even attempted easy there not tywin
this might be the first time we're
seeing it on screen but you tried
telling warner brothers james mangled
and joseph gordon-levitt that that's
never been attempted see what they tell
you i suspect that corinthian inspects
his knife so we'll know he has a knife
and not because he suspects the knife
needs inspecting and i give you a
feather
pulled from an angel's wing whether this
is a literal angel feather or some sort
of bird equivalent that not tywin just
found laying around the house the show
should know we're not going to let the
lack of origin just float by like well a
feather ryder stone explain how a summon
the angel of death spell becomes a bring
me whichever angel happens to be in the
area spell leading me to believe it's
actually a we needed an inciting
incident to set off the next 10 episodes
spell i was powerless against my desire
to narrate my nakedness for the
following morning there were some
sleepers
who could not wake up so there's just no
contingency plan here at all then dream
goes missing and bam the further
collapses and millions of people don't
wake up if the consequences of him
leaving are so dire why does he ever
leave was he really the only person
capable of taking down corinthian do i
know you we sure do but i had no idea
this took place in the logan universe so
seeing donald pierce here is a huge
surprise wait that's not pierce but it
is boyd holbrook but the glasses why the
[ __ ] if they made him look so much like
[ __ ] pierce then not a god
more than a god since most of what
corinthian does here is delivering
exposition it's on that neither he nor
not tywin felt like someone should
expound upon that revelation the circle
will not be enough
you must construct a sphere of glass
inside the circle to contain dream's
physical manifestation look that goes
against everything i've learned on the
nine nightmare on elm street movies but
whatever their forced march tablets
stimulants used to keep trench soldiers
awake the war on drugs day after day he
pleaded for gifts but again he would not
give me pants it's supposed to be
working not reading yeah but it was the
daily mail so i don't think that
technically counts as reading and who
are you to speak for the mages who the
[ __ ] are you good thing these [ __ ]
showed up otherwise ethel would have
needed more screen time to develop into
our new favorite character i could watch
him until they get here if you wanted to
go see you tomorrow cheers alex not
tywin doesn't strike me as being the
forgiving sort so i'm amazed these
numpties think it's okay to leave his
prized [ __ ] possession in the hands
of the offspring that he barely respects
more than a decorative hat rack what
shall we call the fiber game we are the
farber guys considering the one guy
didn't know he was in the fire brigade
i'm gonna guess they weren't in the fire
brigade a few minutes ago so instead of
a snarky comment an explanation would be
more helpful for us to understand why
this job now falls to two people that
look neither equipped nor trained to be
the fire brigade after creating
diversions and doing all that impressive
sneaking the best thing she comes up
with for the final obstacle is pecking
the glass 10 years 10 years she's been
working on that plan you could have
shuttered the glass i suspected that
shooting a shotgun at a glass sphere and
it not breaking was at least a little
[ __ ] and since not tywin agrees that
this was a stupid move i feel
comfortable sending the fact that no
stray pellets appear to even glance off
the glass and and a bird exploding is so
gross we're not going to replay it
you'll just have to watch the show for
yourself and then return to the comments
and explain to me how jessamy's plumage
managed to catch every single pellet
also jessamy was making absolutely no
headway at breaking the glass so the
shotgun was not immediately necessary
i'm adding some extra sins for alex's
overkill and jessamy's underkill a
handful of dust is worth two sand
pouches in a bird okay i'll leave she's
taking it all the helmet the pouch the
ruby the grimoire and 200 000 in cash
she's taken far more than that oh
far more than that you don't say no
really he isn't saying what he means
also ethel escapes by calling a cab
that's it she just packed a bag and
waited outside this is either the most
incompetent house staff in english
history or not tywin is the most stupid
and complacent yet simultaneously genius
and obsessive man on the planet come on
show at least acknowledge one accomplice
to make this believable speak to me
speak to me in the last 10 years what
exactly has stopped not tywin from
performing the ritual again dream is
clearly not capable or entirely
unwilling to help so why didn't he go
back to the summoning board and try to
actually trap death this time if randall
were a light randall for alive he would
hate you as much as i do
kids he's not moving well let's keep
stating the [ __ ] obvious instead of
getting the man any medical attention
yes we know he's dead because we've seen
a tv show before but the character
shouldn't be assuming the same my mum
used to say that if i was good i went to
sleep man would come sprinkle sand in my
eyes and that's supposed to be an
incentive oh my god ah yes my first
dates are often spent in the basement of
a mansion where my recently deceased
father has been hiding a naked dream
angel in a glass fear surrounded by a
moat don't ask who he mistakenly
summoned after originally trying to trap
the angel of death with the intent of
forcing them to summon my dead brother
you know if i can't get theater tickets
just promise that you won't harm me or
paul and i will let you out should i
have believed him this time well the
dream believes paul or not what's the
downside here dream promises not to hurt
them paul keeps his word dream returns
to narnia no more suffering humans job
done if paul doesn't keep his word then
dream just keeps chilling out in the
dark crystal ball exactly as he would if
he just says nothing alright so maybe
the dreamer has no clothes doesn't need
food and maybe the smell in there isn't
as bad as i think it is but there has
got to be a sinful amount of butt cheek
prints on that glass and i will not be
convinced otherwise
over a hundred years and this is the
first time something like this has
happened not the raven juices that were
presumably cleaned up at some point not
the falling body of not tywin who hit
the deck right next to it but a damn
wheelchair swivel
that's what leads to dreams escape y'all
know you want my friend but you chose to
read the sun this would be less
distracting if the show made the mildest
attempt at explaining why all of
mcdreamy's movements seem more about
keeping his penis off screen and less
about well moving do you understand the
damage you've done to your world i'm
sorry i i didn't know how did you not
know there are millions of people with
severe sleeping disorders and you have
sleepy gary the ceo of sleeping
imprisoned in the basement your
punishment then shall be a gift the gift
of eternal sleep sho says it's a gift
and makes it feel like a punishment but
i'm still inclined to view it as a gift
the sin is insomnia more than a century
of tortured sleep great even more
narration i'm getting to think all of
his mystical items are just for
decoration since he's clearly capable of
putting everyone to sleep with his
excessive expositing i can't tell if the
blood dribbling down the face of hungry
eyes means he's a messy eater or that he
bit his little eyelip i'm either going
to sin this for stealing from jeepers
creepers or i'm sending the original
comic for inspiring jeepers creepers in
the first place someone is getting
sinned for that this piece of the palace
roof waiting over 100 years for its big
moment who did this my lord
you are the dreaming the dreaming is you
non-sequiturs and the residents the
palace staff okay we started off well
but got very quickly to the issue of
who's going to make the sandwiches a
this season on at the end of your first
episode is kind of in a mission that you
aren't sure people were convinced to
continue watching so the sin is not
having faith in yourself also spoilers
i don't under i didn't understand a one
word you said father likes to be called
mayors
mean sorcerer i don't care
tonight
we will achieve what no one before us
has even attempted but double backward
somersault threw a hoot while whistling
the star-spangled banner
you call that a knife the power of
christ compels you the power of christ
compels you
sand it's coarse rough and irritating
and it gets everywhere
weeping blood comes merely from the
arrangement of the cheer doctor my dear
gentleman
nothing sinister